quand on cherche à minimiser son
empreinte sur l'environnement ont fait
face à des belle contradiction
par conte avec elles avec leurs traces
qu'on laisse dans l'atmosphère et sur la
planète exo on la voit pas le bon outil
qui nous permet de mesurer une excuse
viable et comment en quelques mots
justes qu'une empreinte environnementale
pour quantifier son empreinte écologique
ça prend les bonnes vieilles donner un
talent très particulier pour la
calculatrice ou encore tout simplement
un outil qui ont été développées exprès
pour ça un des plus connus c'est le
calculateur du global footprint network
si celui qui nous donne une note en nous
attribuant une plusieurs planètes qui
correspondent à notre empreinte
écologique
[Musique]
cinq planètes c'est la moyenne
canadienne mais c'est pas ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une bonne note le tome
1 5 étoiles dans un monde idéal
l'empreinte écologique de chaque
personne devrait pas dépasser une
planète
l'outil pour toutes sortes de questions
par exemple à quelle fréquence
consommez-vous des produits animaux
combien de personnes venir avec vous
combien de kilomètres parcourus ou en
voiture chaque année et fera à la fin du
questionnaire
l'outil nous annonce que ça prendrait
quatre points de planète pour soutenir
notre mode de vie et ceci je m'appelle
stéphane et stéphanie stéphanie de mères
de famille que vous servez avec 450 km
de voiture par semaine l'e10 est
omnivore équilibré mais après un voyage
à cancun par m si je suis ont ainsi dû
mater qui habite en ville
je remplis de l'appeler fabio fabio il
ya la chance de pouvoir se passer de
voiture
les locavores il s'appellerait 20 km de
toulouse par jour mais il fait un grand
voyage outre-mer par année donc son
empreinte monte à 2.6 planète avant que
ça se complique
j'ai fait appel à trois experts de
l'empreinte environnementale pour
m'aider à savoir ce qui se cache
derrière les différents calculateurs
l'idée c'est de prendre en compte tous
les types d'impacts environnementaux que
nos activités peuvent entraîner mais
d'une façon très visuelle donc si j'ai
inclus toutes les ressources dont j'ai
besoin
puis toutes les poules la pollution que
j'ai envoyée à l'environnement puis la
capacité cole environnement de captifs
de de s'adapter à cette pollution là bas
quelle surface de la planète je vais
avoir besoin
en principe si on additionne une surface
de tout le monde bien il faudrait pas
dépasser celle de la planète
il ya aussi des calculateurs qui propose
d'évaluer notre empreinte carbone
c'est-à-dire la quantité de gaz qu'on
aimait en une année par exemple le
chiffre magique selon giec ces deux
tomes si chaque être humain il mettait
seulement deux tonnes de co2 par année y
en aurait plus de problème à part
peut-être celui des bugs et
disparaissent dans ses cheveux
l'empreinte carbone ça va représenter
toutes les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui vont avoir lieu soit dans pour
la production de ce qu'on consomme soit
que nous on va émettre directement par
exemple avec notre transport etc dans
l'empreinte écologique on va uniquement
calculer nos émissions de co2 alors que
dans notre empreinte carbone on va
calculer les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui inclut des émissions de co2
mais qui inclut aussi d'autres émissions
de gaz à effet de serre comme le méthane
comme le petit nitreux qui sont des gaz
à effet de serre qui peuvent avoir un
pouvoir réchauffant traduit donc les
calculateurs d'empreinte carbone font un
peu plus spécifique que ce qui donne une
empreinte écologique
le hic c'est que ce qu'on retrouve en
ligne peuvent nous donner des résultats
vraiment différent de l'un à l'autre
dont jean compact deux parmi les plus
reconnus avec le carbon footprint
calculateur qui est un outil qui a été
développé par une firme britannique
le bilan de fabio s'élève à 6 tonnes
d'équivalent co2 par année par jour
celui de stéphanie monte à 15 h jusqu'à
samedi
mais quand on utilise le calculateur de
carbone boréal qui est un programme de
compensation dgs a été mis au point par
l'université du québec à chicoutimi
empreinte de fabio 200 3.5 et celle de
stéphanie s'élève à 6 tonnes de co2 via
un paquet de raisons qui expliquent les
différences entre les calculateurs le
carbon footprint calculateur par exemple
ils payent beaucoup plus de questions
que la plupart de vos trucs convient je
dépense en une année en vêtements en
jour nos produits pharmaceutiques en
nourriture il a les salons importants
il ya donc des outils qui prennent en
compte pour faire rénover et en a
d'autres qui se concentre juste sur
l'excédent ou autrement dit au minimum
vie génère t ou deux parce qu'on sent
pas même la personne la plus écolo au
monde pauvre vie sans gêne et du dioxyde
de carbone il faut savoir que nous on a
un contexte qui est très particulier
dans la vie draw électricité ce qui est
mais très peu de gaz à effet de serre
par kilowattheure produit par ailleurs
on a notre hiver qui fait en sorte qu'on
se chauffe de l'eau probablement
différemment d'autres régions du monde
on a une population qui relativement
diluée sur un grand territoire donc les
déplacements c'est différent on ne peut
pas produire notre nourriture en hiver
on doit en importer une bonne partie
donc tous ces éléments là font en sorte
que les calculateurs actuels ne sont pas
vraiment adaptées au contexte québécois
par contre il faut voir que on a des
modes de consommation de nord-américains
d'occidentaux donc on consomme
énormément beaucoup de chose comparé à
importer mais si on achète des produits
fabriqués avec de l'électricité produite
avec du charbon en fait on est en train
d'exporter nos impacts environnementaux
en important des produits quelque part
on peut voir ça comme ça mais donc ça
veut dire que si on regarde l'empreinte
du québec sur la base de la consommation
donc tout ce que l'on consomme et non
plus sur la base de la production il
faut multiplier notre empreinte par 1,6
donc on a beaucoup plus d'impact
vis-à-vis de nos modes de consommation
que vis-à-vis de nos modes de production
pour faire une analyse du cycle de vie
on va vraiment décrire toutes les étapes
qu'il faut pour produire quelque chose
et ensuite pour son utilisation et sa
fin de vie et à chacune des étapes qu'on
va comptabiliser les ressources prendre
dont on a besoin et les émissions qu'on
émette dans l'environnement
ensuite ces émissions on va les traduire
en impact sur l'environnement c'est à
dire si j'émets un kilogramme de de
phosphate qu'est ce que ça va avoir
comme empreinte environnementale
ultime ans sur la qualité des
écosystèmes ça c'est une analyse du
cycle d bref si je voulais calculé mon
empreinte environnementale au gramme
près il faudrait que je fasse
l'inventaire de tout ce que j'achète et
de tout ce que je fais en un an
ensuite que j'aille fouiller dans des
grosses banques de données et que je
comptabilise tout ce que je peux lui
aussi 37 ans le pour faire autre chose
comme une maîtrise en terre de
marionnettes par exemple bonjour - s'il
ya un mois s'est posée c'est sûr que les
calculateurs sont pas parfaits ils
peuvent pas poser toutes les questions
mais il se concentre sur les domaines
les plus importants
l'alimentation le transport les sources
d'énergie qu'on utilise si je reprends
ma stéphanie aimons fabio et que je
bouge leur curseur de l'alimentation à 0
produits animaux l'empreinte diminue de
manière significative dans une même
proportion que si on enlève le transport
le revenu est important aussi
statistiquement plus on fait de l'argent
plus on consomme et plus notre empreinte
doit être lourdes
une autre donnée cruciale c'est la
province on se trouve si on reprend
notre mère de famille est neuf et le
batteur et qu'on les envoie en alberta
ou en saskatchewan et ça fait gonfler
leur bilan carbone parce que presque
toute leur production d'électricité
repose sur des combustibles fossiles
les calculateurs qu'on va trouver en
ligne ils sont vraiment utiles ils sont
pas parfaits mais ils sont utiles parce
qu'ils nous donnent
ils nous font prendre conscience qu'on a
une empreinte environnementale et rien
que ça c'est important
et ensuite nous font prendre conscience
aussi où est-ce qu'on aurait
potentiellement le plus d'empreinte
environnementale est ce que le mont vrai
problème c'est que je prends trop
souvent l'avion
c'est un vrai problème il faut que je
m'y attaques dans ces cas là on n'a
aucune idée de l'ordre de grandeur de
ces choses là donc qu'ici je m'en vais
faire mes courses en voiture puis à
j'oublie mes sacs réutilisables est ce
que je retourne
d'abord puis je retourne chez moi les
chercher ben si on fait un très simple
calcul on va se rendre compte qu'on est
beaucoup mieux joué quelques sacs de
plastique pour une fois que de faire
quelques kilomètres en voiture pour
aller les rechercher à la maison et ceux
ci le calcul pour bruxelles c'est
certain les citoyens ne sont pas les
seuls et qu'on va pas mettre faire tout
reposer sur les épaules des citoyens
c'est une façon d'entraîner la route
vers un changement positif qui est
essentiel par contre c'est clair qu'il
faut continuer aussi à accompagner des
entreprises à produire de manière plus
durable et le gouvernement un rôle clé à
jouer donc le dire chacun a son rôle à
jouer
finalement c'est pas très grave c'est
les calculateurs son poste s'il près 6
ils peuvent être super pratique pour
repérer une petite contradiction ou
savoir là où on doit mettre nos efforts
ou ne le plus de marge de manoeuvre
mais je veux juste répéter une petite
chose c'est qu'il ya vraiment personne
de parfait quand même beaucoup de gens
qui amorce des changements en même temps
tout le monde sauvegarde qui savent plus
qui est des choses ridicules des
contradictions qui émergent çà veut pas
seulement dire qu'on est en transition
[Musique]